foreign
Albany New York what's up Charles
hey I'm excited to be on the world's
greatest mental health and occasionally
architecture podcast I've been trying to
talk about Home Remodeling I am I'm an
expert in Home Remodeling
um I'm actually an expert in starting no
I'm an expert in watching a bunch of
HGTV and getting a great idea and then
buying a bunch of junk and starting a
project and then never finishing it
that's one of my uh one of my gifts
awesome yeah
out in the world for you do what
can I put an idea out in the world for
you I would love that
I think you should do an entire episode
where everybody sings the whole time but
nobody ever refers to it and you can be
like can I be real with you real real
real real with you yes please and genius
Chuck dude you've just yeah yes and yes
yes
I awesome I'm looking forward to seeing
it and no exit I would delete that
episode out of my own feet but it would
be worth doing this it'd be incredible
right after Hamilton part two comes out
we'll do it that'll be incredible we'll
have one oh that'd be so good actually
and if we could have one guy that just
like metal core sings it another guy
that raps it and that dude this is
Legend way to go man I'm gonna think
about this all day all right all right
so what's up
yeah so my question to you is how do I
stop comparing myself to my wife and I
can provide more contact so you can just
riff off of that please provide more
context
sure does she have better hair than you
is she prettier than like what does she
have like why are you comparing her
what's the deal those things are true
but you know something that you
frequently talk about out is how sort of
a lot of our happiness is based on the
picture we have of our life right in
most ways my life is actually much
better than I expected I have
interesting work that you know pays me
more than I I thought I'd ever make my
kids are awesomeer than I thought you
know my wife as cool as I thought we'd
live in about you know so far so good
but I can't help but sort of look to my
right and see you know I'm middle
management a large company my wife is a
c-suite executive at a company you know
she helped take public last year you
know our kids are closer emotionally to
my wife
and if I'm being honest with myself
she's just frankly smarter than I am
and you know that's not because I'm
stupid it's because she's legitimately
brilliant right
um and you know you can sort of you read
about her in the newspaper or in you
know magazine sort of come to the same
conclusion this person
brilliant so it's sort of like you know
being married to Athena I'm like well
you know I'm doing well for Immortal but
I'd like to be able to step on a cloud
and fly up to Mount Olympus too yeah and
it just you know it's a little hard to
to let go of that what is what is your
jealousy getting you
it gives you something what is it giving
you
and this isn't a trick question I'm
literally asking you it it solves a
problem for you in your life what is it
yeah I mean so
there is a bit more to the story
in the sense that I had
two pictures actually of my life that
were mutually incompatible
and I very explicitly
had to choose
One path to be with Leah and
maybe it's sort of
helps me
deal with sort of the loss of
the other
path that you know I enjoyed a lot were
you going to be an actor or something
like that in in art and you had to go
make a living
no
International humanitarian worker in
Warzone yep and I I got to do that but I
sort of
really push the boundaries of safety to
the point where you know my wife was
saying look you know when I say tilt
that do us part I need that to be a long
time about a short time from now
so hold on hold on at that exact moment
at that moment
your wife presented you with a choice
you chose her
right I did okay
any
any energy
spent going back and trying to re-edit
that decision
is a choice to be miserable in the
present
I had to do it too
I've done it several times
and I find myself when I'm tired when
I'm exhausted or when I'm feeling less
than I fall back into it
stop decisions I made 20 years ago
before I got married
my wife and I broke up what was going to
be the last time for about a year a long
time because I here was my rationale if
everything works out in my life the way
I want it to all my dreams come true and
all of your dreams come true we will end
up on opposite sides of the planet
and so why would we be together
knowing we're walking in and neither of
us are going to get what we think that
would fulfill us and what I found in
that journey is something I didn't know
existed
but that was my rationale and actually
logically that makes good logical sense
and it was the stupidest thing I've ever
the stupidest Choice I've ever made
but I tell you all that to tell you
you are really good linguistically
you can I bet people love being around
you at a party and you can be fun
and you can talk your way in and out of
things pretty well
yeah but
you underneath all of that are choosing
misery why what is it getting you
your kids aren't hanging out with your
wife because she's brilliant they're
hanging out with her more because she's
safer
you have a core of radioactivity about
you what is it and don't talk eloquent
just be direct what is it
only child don't care don't care you're
a grown man what what what is it getting
you
foreign
I'm not always comfortable being around
surrounded by people and actually
somewhat introverted despite being
exuberant in certain circumstances there
you go
yeah
okay
so I I can't always handle like the
constantness of
just being a parent to three kids who I
I love like they're they're in
somebody's I love being a father more
than I thought but I like parenting
maybe less than I thought here's the
deal brother here's the deal you like
the idea of liking things you don't like
them and you're not honest to yourself
about it
you like the idea of being a dad
you like the idea of being married to a
really brilliant powerful woman you like
the idea of working in a cool company
but you don't actually like the work
what do you actually like dude
I mean I think I love no no no what do
you actually like you're always saying
maybe and I think you know what do you
actually like
I love adventure and being in crazy
circumstances that I've never
experienced before yes and parenting is
so boring is
so boring
so boring and then you try to go on
adventure and one of your kids is like
I'm tired can I get a snack and you're
just like oh my God I get it yes
and so here's what's happening
you have a thing inside of you you love
Adventure
in a weird way you and I are very
similar I I don't have any interest in
going and being on the front lines in
third world countries and all that like
that's not my thing
but I did for about for multiple years
um
after my kids went to bed I went and ran
around with police officers in the
middle of crazy death scenes
because I needed that right yeah I went
and found it
but if you but right now you're doing it
at you're just not having this thing and
it is dragging everything else down
yeah see what I'm saying
yeah
and I don't think your wife's relate
your relationship with your wife is
worth that I don't think your
relationship with your with your kids is
worth that I don't think in the reverse
is true
but you're on a fast track to resentment
brother and then right after resentment
is comes entitlement and then that's
when you start doing stupid things man
is that fair
yeah I mean I I hope I have the
self-awareness to be able to say my
emotional reaction is unfair
I mean my wife isn't putting any of
these expectations on me it's entirely
self-generated but you're trying to
solve all of this in your head and you
can't you have to act
right yes no I my whole family tree
we're all in our heads for Generations
mine too you gotta act you have to do
different things and so when someone
says Hey how do I stop being jealous of
my partner I tell them go be more
awesome
because the focus isn't on them the
focus is you are miserable as a middle
manager at a regular size corporation
surrounded by three kids in a big city
you see what I'm saying and when that
happens we make it everybody else it's
these stupid kids are just doing XYZ
it's my spouse is all brilliant I'm not
good enough that's not the issue that's
us trying to throw fishing lines of
blame out there and catch something that
will make us feel ah it's because of my
childhoods because I'm an only kid no I
don't care about any of that stuff it
probably matters down the way I just
don't care about it
right what I care about is you making a
couple of choices to be alive
that don't involve cheating on your wife
and they don't involve leaving your kids
yeah I mean occasionally I've I've found
opportunities that have a lot of
interesting international travel that do
make me feel alive but
it can create tension because I'm away a
lot and I don't actually want to be a
bad partner or parent and it kind of can
be an addiction absolutely it is what
are you running from
in some ways maybe the drudgery of life
like when you're
on the front lines it's very interesting
you don't have to do laundry and you
don't have to cook your own food
um
I
I don't have a good answer
um how old are your kids
nine seven and four okay
let me let me
two things number one your kids are
watching their dad and they're learning
a picture of what Dad is supposed to be
and if Dad is kind of frumped out
and
let me put this away they will feel
whether you ever say it or not that
they're the reason you're not happy
because happiness is only on the front
lines of a thing
your wife will always feel that she
didn't fill in the blank
and they don't deserve that
definitely not what I would
your mission right now brother is to
come alive
and you're in a season
hang on and don't do something stupid
you're in a season man nine seven and
four
dude you've got three elementary school
kids
and one place you'll have a house or
apartment
we we have a house okay yeah yeah man
you're in a season so the question is
sitting down with your wife and saying
hey what do you need in this season
here's what I need I need some Adventure
I need to get my heart rate up that
might be in the bedroom that might be
I'm gonna join an MMA team I might be
mean I'm just starting to ride along
with the police department that might
mean I'm gonna
get a weekend job cleaning window I
don't know what gets your heart rate up
but let's say okay I can't go to
um the latest I can't go to Somalia I
can't go to wherever
where can I find purpose and Mission and
become alive in my current environment
in this season
yeah
see what I'm saying
it's like when I find myself in a hotel
room okay I don't have a huge gym what
can I do here right now that's going to
get my heart rate up it's going to keep
me healthy
it's not gonna be the greatest workout
ever I'm not going to get shredded bro
and Crossfit and that's none of that's
gonna happen
but I'm gonna be able to sleep tonight
I'm gonna feel good and I'll have moved
my body and I'll keep moving myself down
the road towards becoming the guy I want
to be
yeah no that that all makes sense I mean
I I think I'm somebody who's naturally a
little bit
dissatisfied yes
um
why what are you dissatisfied from
state of the world the state of myself
I'm not quite as you know awesome as I
like to be hey okay so that was Jolly
Charles
you know kind of you know
I think you don't like you
I don't think you like the way you look
I don't think you don't like your job I
don't think you I think there's several
you just don't like you
why don't you like you
I think I could have done more with the
opportunities I've been given there you
go
foreign
so you feel like you're a failure and
you feel ashamed and you feel like man I
blew it
and now I'm stuck for the next 25 years
and then after that I'm like 58.
right
and then you fall into the boat that
most men fall into which is the one the
boat taking us on our lives of quiet
desperation this is just the way this is
going to be
and you'll either cheat on your wife and
everyone will be like what she was
brilliant beautiful what is he doing and
you will say because I finally felt
alive
or you will leave your kids and go to
some first world country or third world
country and to do a thing and you will
the whole time you're like I'm doing
good work my kids will
you're chasing something because you
can't look in the mirror and be happy
with who you see so what I would tell
you is maybe you did maybe you had some
cool opportunities and you blew it I
don't think so but maybe that's maybe
it's true
yeah here's the reality there's a period
at the end of that sentence
now what
because by continuing to focus on the
things you you've blown in the past you
screwed up in the past
you're screwing up your present
you're not living full see what I'm
saying
yeah that's that brick in the backpack I
talk about all the time
you wake up every morning with jolly
Charles and you open up your backpack
and you're like good morning and you
just start picking up the bricks and
putting them in there putting them in
there putting them in there I'm carrying
this around
and I guess so is are we meant to be
satisfied I mean in some ways
restlessness
has created
opportunity for me and I I make a lot of
strange choices but also that leads to
some really interesting outcomes
so I certainly understand
what you're saying
but also there's a part of me that if I
was too self-satisfied I'd be
dissatisfied with that
you've bought into an insane lie
that
if you are at peace and you have joy in
your life that you can't be ambitious
that you can't go do good things
and that's Madness
in fact I would say the only way you can
do something good and healthy and well
sustainably over time is to find
equilibrium and then anchor off of there
and here's the here's the Charles curse
you're going to over analyze everything
yes and you're going to over analyze and
you're going to over analyze you're
going to over analyze and that's going
to keep you that's your buffer from ever
having to do anything
and so you're gonna have to choose when
those like Yeah but isn't nope stop I'm
not having that conversation I'm going
to exercise
okay yeah but nope I refuse to have that
com yes a Wandering spirit is good I
have one all over the place and I
desperately need people that keep me
Bound in
I love when I get nervous or I'd like I
go into my head I just sit there with my
data and I read and I need somebody to
say go to the gym
right right
you don't have man you don't have a a
you've bound yourself up into and tied
yourself to a mast of a ship heading in
just a circle in the bay
because it's just the way this is
I'm not meant to be at peace that's
stupid man yes you are
I'm Not Meant To Be You Are
and you can find adventure and you can
come alive in a million different ways
right where you're sitting
to feel like you have to have Adventure
overseas and to abandon your family and
to leave your wife
that's not about Adventure and that's
not about fulfillment that's about
running
and
you're worth peace
stay on the line I'm going to send you
on your pass change your future I want
you to read it all the way through and I
want you to call me back
um
yours is kind of an extreme example
because your wife's super successful but
your situation is very very common and
I'm willing to walk alongside you if
you'll uh give me a call back in a
couple of months and let's continue to
walk down this road together